we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p our callers
today has identified another bit of
hypocrisy from the right-wing take a
listen to this hey David um hey after
all of these right-wing protests where
they're blocking traffic stopping nurses
from getting a hospital like all that
stuff can these right wing lunatics who
love to say that you know whatever the
left of this the last oh they they block
traffic or do all these protests oh all
this stuff can can they like shut us up
and never ever ever again say that this
is a live look this is for loops this is
a left
yeah so listen you're absolutely right
and and there's actually a bigger
hypocrisy so first of all the right
often likes to say you know these
lefties with no job they'll-they'll
brought block traffic they prevent
people who need to get to work from
getting to work get a job
losers or Laura right you know that now
they are blocking traffic they are
preventing ambulances from getting to
hospitals to get people care because
they are protesting the lockdown orders
but there's a bigger hypocrisy it is
these supposed law-and-order
right-wingers who love to say obey
authority obey authority and yet here
the authorities medical and political
are saying stay the hell home this is
dangerous wear a mask social distance
now they say obey authority these are
oppressive people who have declared
themselves kings the hypocrisy is bigger
than just the blocking traffic my friend
we have a great bonus show for you today
don't miss it get instant access by
signing up at join pakman.com